all right so obviously somebody's
missing there seems to be a hole in the
panel now on other genre shows like Game
of Thrones for example you know kid
Harrington we don't believe he's dead at
least not a TW so there's always a
chance that characters can come back to
life
can we expect that with Juliet no no oh
but on behalf of bits II want to thank
everybody for coming here and waiting in
line we still appreciate the fans amen
and we can't do without you
so that's it just this flat out no you
don't want to like tease us with
anything more anything could happen but
he speaks with forked tongue all right
so you have picked up for a third season
I wonder if you can go back we obviously
got a little taste of it there this
season yay yeah can you go back give me
the narrative thread let's go through
each season quickly what each season met
if you like the one story for each
season what what take me up to here well
you get the first season he was just
discovering how to be a Grimm and his
mommy showed up at the end the second
season I don't know you know I did kind
of scribe it he was his mom be at the
end of one stage I tried to kill him and
he survived and he lost his Grimm and
got that back and this year's going to
be the rise of the vest and it's going
to be kind of a revolutionary type vest
and group that want to wreak havoc upon
every one of our beloved people now you
got a big birthday coming up you're
hitting your hundredth you've got
anything planned for that we do at last
we're going to explain the damn keys
we still don't know what they do but by
god we're good
before I asked a few more questions guys
this is your show this is your time to
ask your questions if you want to line
up now I want to get in as many as I can
so start them now so we can get your
questions and you get a lot to forget to
ask before I get into the specifics I
know the show is very big
internationally can you guys not walk
through Frankfurt Airport and like it
you know slammed what about an eight
David are you big I know it's truly like
I was in Kenya two years ago and I was
in this little mall and these girls
Kenyan girls are like what are you doing
here so ya know we I like everywhere all
the other countries we um there's my
face on the screen with some overdubbing
you know it's kind of wild did you meet
your kenyan voice-over artist speak
english over there um so thank you oh I
have not met any voiceover artists at
mime what about the rest of you do you
have any um lovely sweet international
fan encounters that you'd like to share
I was hiking at the very very peak of
Machu Picchu and just before I reach the
summit all I heard was all these fans
from Brazil was amazing kind of you know
ruin the moment but it was fantastic it
was very grateful for that anyone else
like to jump in when you're in Bali
anything on the beaches of Bali nothing
I guess not all right all right David I
want to start with you where are you
gonna pick up now are you gonna focus on
being a good dad or is it all about
revenge for you yeah well those can be
both the same thing still I need a lot
of revenge and then Adalind and I after
like co-parent which is gonna be so
bizarre for me or for Nick um but no I
think I think that Nick really just
wants to you know he lost his girlfriend
he lost his mom he lost well something
in the first episode of next season and
I think the baby is kind of the reason
for me to kind of keep going so yeah I
think I'll go with dad
and when he's not around it's all
revenge yeah
all right Russell this one's for you
will Hank find some true love this next
year what has been promised for you well
in fact Hank doesn't know yet he's going
to yes we didn't know that you didn't
know it but yes is the answer
oh he's gone out any cast ideas
producers what can you tell us what can
you tease about that yes
about his love he falls he falls you
don't wanna give too much away is what
you're saying would you ask about a true
love will you find some true love he
knows nothing you're calling it
well III know about the Blues know what
to go put up all right then Silas how
about you let's let's talk a little bit
about Minh Rosalie what what's good tell
me about the journey of this this
pairing and will your love be tested is
your love being tested will be tested
going forward what do you know all I
know is that in the same way that I
think I was tried last year I think
something comes up for Rosalie I think
I've been clear to say tries her
similarly and and then I think in the in
the same way that you were left behind
while I was getting dealt with in a
certain way I think I'm in a position I
think something in that I think you're
imperiled somehow something from your
past can you talk about well I think I
think I've been cleared we'll find out
that um
Rosalie's you know she came on the scene
very guarded and alone in dealing with
the past of addictions and you know
that's been shelves for good reason
because she's found new meaning in her
life and her the love of her life
but I think I think her addictions come
back into the storyline and that causes
some major problems for the couple
so don't she attacked a lot addiction to
cardigan sweaters an addiction to the
lands in catalogue he says the whole
Rosalee Monroe where birth tones isn't
listened to earth tone matching olive
drab and rust no I think she really
struggles with some Semih cardigan
excuse me I'm gonna keep going she
really struggles with her past skeletons
that come back I think the people really
dig you what kind of feedback do you get
from the fans for your pre relationship
today what do they want more of us thank
you no I I think it's it you know I
think it was really drawn well by the
men in charge I think it was drawn well
it was slow it was kind of awkward and
sweet and organic and I think that just
resonated with people it wasn't sort of
like they go on a date they go to bed
they're a couple and then you're in
couple Ville for a long time they spent
a long time in the in-between and I
think the in-between is interesting to
people and I think there are two people
with complicated paths and there are
they're not perfect and they help each
other and support each other which is
what real partnership should be about so
and we bicker - I mean it's not all
perfect yeah I like how they bring that
yeah like last year you know there were
things like I don't want to why are we
doing that why are we you know
why is Adalind in our living room you
know and you're much more your old flame
no your what oh you mean you mean
Angelina Angelina not putting up her
name I'm sorry I'm sorry no no sorry
that's my bad I heard about the the pig
the ear x fo oh the Balor's fine Merson
yeah that that lovely fight we oh yeah a
good one which was yeah
in your own caucus right now production
thank you thanks for coming all right
Reggie just want to see you talk to me
about what sergeant Wu brings to the
table what do you are you more relevant
than ever to this group
what do you bring to the team talk about
when your brain sees this is this a
question for me way down at the end I
bring doughnuts to the team okay listen
I think is is the newest if overzealous
initiate into the Scooby Gang I find
myself bringing some smarts to the team
so in a lot of technical skills so
hopefully those will be put to use in
this next year but I hear it's going to
be a hard a freshman year for me so
we'll see we'll see what happens with
that but it's been it's been a lot more
work but I'm so happy to do it and I get
to be with these guys more so it's been
it's been fantastic like Reggie we've
all want to see we want to see more Wuan
more outfits he's very handsome man we
got to get him out of that one thinking
out there I have more oh yes sir you
know eyelet I have more outfits I bring
more outfits to this season all right um
this is for Sasha now I know that I
should be asking you about you know the
captain's rise to power and and maybe
coming to blows with Nick but all I
really care about is how much more we
will see you take your shirt off
please talk about the evolution of this
development I mean is this something
that started me I mean it was like to
just take off in the first season then
with like okay this is something we got
to keep recurring with it's just good to
ative it just do it yet
she's asking when it took off I took off
pretty quickly um yeah the shirtless
rage thing became a human thing I think
but it had to be painful so someone
someone someone asked me recently
what's your xalbert beast power and I
said well it's ripping off my shirt in
under three seconds basically I'm very
flattered yeah it's it's you know it's
it's a thing do you feel objectified in
the most wonderful way all right yeah
David I don't mean to objectify you but
we talked about taking your shirt off
listen I pale in comparison to shots -
Sasha Roy's here oh don't don't you
darling his chest people I was shirtless
on a treadmill once and I think the
feedback wasn't as glorious so so
they've kept my shirt on all right start
some no seriously seriously now let's
talk about the captain's rise to power
word he wears worse things Goines with
this man well I think the royal family
won't be as much of a issue I think that
that sort of been quelled for the time
being yeah they all died so that's yeah
issue resolved and I think there's a lot
of political opportunity for him coming
up certainly at least regionally and
there's also a lot of uprising
situations which he'll be a part of I
think so we're getting back to a lot of
the mythology of season 1 and some of
those intricate webs and politics that
we saw him not be a part of some looking
forward to that I'm gonna ask a question
of Claire and then I'm gonna toss it to
you guys to get ready all right Claire
what about Adeline now is what's her
focus now she's just gonna be the good
mom is she going to be the mother of the
year where's it going with her
yes mother of the year
been bandied about for Adalind uh I
think it really this baby is all she's
got again in the world so but I think
now she has so much more perspective
she's lost her powers again uh but I
think this time yeah the focus really
will be the baby and then also finding a
job so you know what can she do
what will she sees and we're so told
everybody for yes she is a lawyer I am a
very capable lawyer so hopefully I so
scour Craigslist for a couple episodes
and then hopefully figure it out yeah I
wish her well
alright thank my we've got some
questions let's let's start them up
I thought you is there anyone there I
can't see yes I can see we get the
lights on that lovely person there we go
my man what do you got your hand there
no do you 22 pic is greatly nice oh
thank you I think you guys are passing
them out to everyone so we appreciate it
thank you we've been seeing your panel
for was since you guys started so we're
so I'm so excited to have gotten into
Hall 20 to see you we're very happy to
have you here I did want to say to
silence as well go UCSD I hear you're a
peter grad from there I went to the
Masters theater program in this city yes
I learned a lot about directing not so
the Juliet thing has somewhat been
answered so will she be back next season
and flashbacks at all and what emotional
arc Nick was he's gonna follow this
season
a great big emotional arc as Jesse will
come back in flashbacks more than likely
yeah and always yeah I can tell you
here's I mean there's nothing more he
can can you talk a little bit about that
emotional arc I mean what is that what
does that mean what kind of for Nick yes
well as David said he's lost absolutely
everything and you
we found his mom's head in a box no he
didn't get a baby he got a baby out of
it it'll take you a day to find your
mom's head in a box though I know this
from personal experience I mean yeah he
said it best
I suppose write what you know all right
next please go ahead
hello my name is Enrique and I'm
seriously a fan of the show like huge I
love you guys oh nice very sweet Monroe
Rosalee you guys are my favorite we
loved watching your relationship grow on
the show thank you during the episode
when Monroe was taken captive and
Rosalee had a fight with Juliette it
really scared me and I wanted to know if
if you worry when reading your script if
your characters are ever in danger of
being like oh are you kidding me I got
to page 15 I was like oh quit wait what
yeah I call my husband I was like do not
move to Portland I've just been killed
no you know we were kind of like you in
a way we we don't really have a lot of
prep on the storyline it's also what
makes episode television really fun you
know it's just like life you don't know
what you're doing tomorrow
we don't know where do you but uh every
script could be your last
but ya know I think that's what makes
this genres so fun is that it's
limitless in that sense that really
anything goes yes
job security maybe maybe a little shaky
but uh in terms of the imagination it's
it's a blast for all those reasons
you're so sweet I know thank you so much
man thanks all right next hello my name
is Rachel I have a question for the
captain how did you feel about playing
Jack the Ripper oh I loved it it was uh
it was fun to have this completely um
you know this huge departure from the
captain Lee that's just psychopaths who
can't get enough fun and I mean while
the name Jack's yeah for him it was but
less free I can tell you he was having a
lot of fun a lot of fun I know we hadn't
was now we had a great time you know
again it was yeah it was such a
wonderful departure that that we had up
we had a blast doing it and a lot of
laughs I think it was the first time we
saw the captain's teeth like smelly you
might have seen his teeth yeah all
righty
he has teeth next place hi my name is
clarissa and my question is for the
writers how do you feel about killing
off a major character and by that I mean
the trailer and I guess Juliet too but
haha good one we hated to lose the
trailer but you know it's a huge
decision to do something like that and I
can't say we're jumping up and down with
joy but it seemed like the next step
that had to happen to the show and it
seemed like something that character
would do so we loved the carriage but it
wasn't really herself anymore she become
a bad excellent but then the the
basement of the spice shop is now the
rebirth of
trailer that's in a really cool way so
the information is still there what
didn't burn as writers though where do
the fans come into your mind when you're
writing these scripts knowing I mean do
you allow them to enter the equation or
I mean is it just focus I got it you
know I got to focus on the story that I
got to focus on the story because
obviously there's going to be some
concern about how they may react well we
we take that into consideration when we
write these things and sometimes you
just have to go with it because it's the
right thing for the characters to do and
hopefully the fans will write along with
us alrighty next with the ears hi my
name is Breanna I'm and my sisters are a
huge fan of your show um I have a
question for Monroe and rosalee's the
stylist and Bri
we were wondering soon in the season
since you guys got married if you're
going to be having a baby soon every
time someone asks that I just say for
Hara sure which is which is what our
baby might be if we had one at the type
of creature that it would be is a funny
sounding word that's all I can sweet
well they hinted on it during the
fertility episode last season that
groovy bunny rabbit Lucky's rabbits but
which I thought was so good I love that
episode with the bunnies but it was so
gross like they're having sex with the
bird but mm-hmm
it was nasty David under the bed but I
thought that scene was really sweet
where I think it kind of touched on the
future of this question which is there
at the time they're of the age you know
to really like if it's going to happen
needs to happen now and they're scared
so they're just real people um so
perhaps perhaps perhaps it's gonna be a
whole hash hop producers perhaps you you
echo that this is frankly perfect
because there's a half there's a lot of
babies been running around
so I don't know you can't have too many
babies on a show like this so I think
everybody should have a baby even David
literally alright next go ahead
hi my name is Darius I have a question
about the third season finale when Nick
lost his powers and Nick Monroe bogged
in front of him shouldn't Nick have been
able to see it because Monroe wanted to
be seen no he only wanted to be seen by
a Grimm he was in stage one there's two
days Riki stage it's very complicated
formula but we don't even understand it
I know that that is a good question but
but the point is that that you know
there was that episode when the guys
were robbing the banks right and they
were purposefully wanting to be seen by
cares I - by normies which is a which is
something that is you know you're
breaking the gazettes book Aaron codex
to do that that's like verboten it's not
allowed what I was doing
he's in character right now what are we
talking about here I mean where's the
less inhabit the world if we're going to
inhabit the world right I mean this
question is going deep so I'm going to
respond in kind and I love it but as
David said the Volga for him was
specifically to see if he could see me
as a Grimm the other people in the room
I don't think could see me there you go
Thanks goodbye
all right next question hi my name is
Sam and I was wondering this is for the
producers by the way where you get your
inspiration for some of your bizarre
potions and contraptions
that's good question it's a lot of time
laying on a couch reli they're together
and somehow we get inspired it comes
from everywhere it comes from all over
the world you know the gardels
yeah history the history and the
Brothers Grimm you know had 200 stories
but only about eight or nine of them
would anybody know if he has stories
like the donkey and the sausage go to
town and play the piano and we haven't
figured out how to adapt that kind of
stuff also we're desperate to get paid
so we dig and dig but everything is
based in some kind of fact who we always
try to find some kind of basis for it
alright next hi my name is Rhon and all
of you are great look I think all of you
are just spectacular characters but the
music I think is also a huge component
of your show recommend so my question is
really to the producers to the composer
of the show
do you give him direction or you just
give him the script and let him cut
loose and I'm asking cuz I'm a commuter
he doesn't get the script he gets the
cut that we deliver that's the first
time he sees it he doesn't read it he's
amazing Rick Marvin and we have an awful
lot of music in the show and my
aesthetic used to be don't have too much
music but this guy is so amazing that it
just carries the show and pretty much
leave them alone pretty much yeah he
usually he delivers and he does do
incredible music in a short amount of
time it's unbelievable
all right next hi my name's Johnson I
don't know then this is what like haha
this is what the cat if you would switch
pots with which pot would you switch
with I would like to play the captain
because I would like to do nothing but
um scowl and not have something bit more
intricate than I have to say as many
words you let him say that I would
actually switch with Monroe perfect
let's do it you won't do it let's do it
Johnson thank you for the idea I think
I'd love to be Adeline I'll say I want
to be Adeline let's just do it let's
just let soon I guess that leaves me you
and me hey good switch let's do it I
wanna be we were just - my shirt off
yeah
want to be Norberto this stunt for
February or May switching roles like
that let's do it alright next next
thanks John simply good questions
Johnson my name is Rosie and my
questions for Reggie
why did Wu beat up Nick and Hank when he
found out he wasn't actually crazy
because look at them and then look at me
uh you know I think it's it's it's on a
serious note I really had to kind of
work that out in my actory mind and go
through it and I did have that one big
outburst outside the house where I
eventually started seeing things again
but it's you know there's a whole deep
relationship with these guys and a
friendship with these guys and as you
can see with Wu now he's kind of really
into this stuff and so he there was that
part that was like wow what is this
whole other world and these two guys
know all about it so there is an initial
anger I have to say that that that was
there and if it wasn't there I wouldn't
be human but then who is really human in
this show so but that's a great question
it's a great question it's something
I've had to work through and I'm still
working through it there are times I'm
pissed off right and I let it go with
little sarcasm I saw it's covering up
very deep wounds that surgeon yes deep
wounds but um all right next
thank you go ahead hi I'm Tamara this is
Lorelei and what do you know she had
pretty much the same question I had so
what I want to know then is are we going
to see maybe a resurgence of bitterness
in your role to come because you're
going through your feelings is it for me
you know what I think here's here's the
thing as an actor I don't think as a
person is a human
we all kind of carry those things always
right I mean there's very few things
really in life if you've been scarred by
say seeing someone turn into a creature
that that you did someone a good friend
not telling you that they knew that the
whole time and made you go crazy and go
to the psych ward
I think I'd carry that with me a little
bit um I think it's always gonna be
there with with who with me and I hope
it would because that's part of the
journey that's part of the the joy of
doing this is finding the other side
right now I'm on that side where I'm
like come on I want this crime to be a
Besant crime please
so I can find out more and that's kind
of hidden in the back but I'm sure
someday hopefully it'll surface again
next hi I'm Helen I was wondering what
your favorite Bethan or monster on the
show so far that you faced to span which
can i which one is the leech is that the
gallon K this kilink itis is no no no no
no he's the crocodile what's the leech
cuz I liked him yes long no no the
Leoben Sheldon
I thought holy gallon hi dad oh yeah
a slug with teeth yeah [ __ ] teeth yeah
I knew that one
I like the I wasn't in this episode but
this is Benetton that's my favorite TV
god is good but it's not with the spider
right they for a bit of the mouse yes
yes close we did a little episode called
Krampus
that was the which was a couple seasons
ago man so this guy we had was like I've
never seen him out of makeup so in my
head he's just this giant man who am ii
was giant and he was a really good actor
and he was dressed as Santa and he had
these like horns and I just kind of
that's how I met him and and and it was
really bizarre and he was kind of like
verbally enjoying like the and and I
thought he played it really well so that
Krampus was pretty fun I think that same
guy played Vulcan Alice oh yes well
connected went out here and then I think
the Golem guy too so he plays like all
the big oh yes we have we have like an
in-house giant actor who really does
happen to be quite good I think you yeah
even a word naughty feels naughty
alright next go ahead hi my name is
Simon and my question was if we're going
to get to see a Grimm's eyes from the
vestment perspective these are great
questions people that's nice we might
have a right question and you know we've
described what it looks like looking
into sort of the void I don't know how
to physically show that be black okay
I'd be dark dark dark so maybe
okay thanks bro alright next hi my name
is Trisha and I wanted to know now that
Julia is gone if we were gonna see Ariel
Evan Hart
Daniel Pam Baker come back oh wow season
1 as a season 1 callback she was great
all that hot seat was though oh the
drugs smoking younger I think I remember
staying oh ok Damon Damon darn good idea
wait did you answer oh I guess that's a
no that's a is it Mason maybe another
man maybe ok maybe baby
alright go ahead I think we have time
for one more question
oh quickly yes hey I'm Natasha so
question for the producers next baby's
going to be half Hexenbiest half Grimm
how is that going to be like any special
powers is it going to be weird
all the rougher door it's gonna know how
to pee and poop and nurse pretty good
but beyond that we don't really know yet
I'm you brought up the vest and I can
you tease any new vests in that we will
see in the coming season
yes we're going to do the Loch Ness
monster coming up nice and yeah it's
gonna be gonna explain that in the Grimm
world we have a Gila monster gila
monsters new he's kind of you huh kiha
to view whatever that looks like he had
a beam yeah yeah that's a Gila monster
it's funny because you read scripts and
all I'm like I wonder what that thing is
gonna look like it is yeah just a word
all right I think we have to say goodbye
unless there's something in particular
you all want to say to them thank you
thank you for coming up you're
appreciating the show yeah got me a key
I think not thank you guys
you